hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well near the
innovative mega mechanics book 7
Aristotle discusses the nature and value
of pleasure one of the topics that he
discusses that's quite interesting is
the desirability of bodily pleasures and
he notes that there are some people who
are suspicious of pleasure all together
and we've already talked about that in
another video but there are some people
who say well you know pleasure is ok but
bodily pleasures really not very good at
all as a matter of fact that's for the
common people or that's that's you know
base or or harmful it really should be
just about say mental pleasures or
pleasures of the soul that your subtle
is somewhat receptive to that he thinks
that bodily pleasures are not the be-all
and end-all they're not the the great
measure for the nature of pleasure he
does think that some people get that
wrong but he also wants to understand
but why is it that we actually find
bodily pleasures so desirable not only
ourselves but other people so you know
he starts out by thinking in terms of
human beings as being
capable of a very wide range of
pleasures this is something that shows
up in his discussions not only in this
work but in many other places as well
just think about the pleasure of taste
he contrasts human beings to other
animals other animals like to eat this
or they like to eat that they enjoy this
thing or that thing we already actually
omnivores you know we're we're not only
sort of a universal kinda animal with
respect to building you know technology
and tools and use of the mind and reason
and all that sort of stuff we're also
universal the fact that will eat just
about anything in front of mate or
another and generally find some way to
make it tasty as a matter of fact in
this very section Aristotle mentions the
art of cookery as one that we could say
is an art designed to give pleasure
right but then let's sort of a scientist
you now some pleasures Aristotle thinks
are are better than other pleasures and
he talks about this in terms of them
being more noble this word noble that
I've got your cologne you know being
fine also it's important to point out
that in other places he'll talk about
the noble or the fine person as being
the genuine criterion for what is what
is genuinely pleasant hill talking about
some pleasures being naturally pleasant
but not being naturally Pleasant in that
same way necessarily to everybody
because they haven't you know
sufficiently appreciated those pleasures
those are pleasures that don't involve
pain in some way and to understand what
he means by that let's think about what
he calls restorative pleasures quite a
few of the pleasures that we experience
involve a kind of setting things back
into equilibrium setting things back
into balance consumption of food
consumption of liquid when we're thirsty
great examples of this sleeping in on a
on a Saturday morning perhaps even into
the afternoon because we've got a long
week of work
and not getting enough sleep that could
be another example of restorative
pleasure Aristotle tends to think about
sexual activity and desire pleasure
probably orgasm things like that along
those same lines as well and we might
come up with many other examples
Aristotle also thinks that it's possible
for a person to need in the sense of
that restorative pleasure things that
are naturally that way so you know when
we talk about somebody experiencing
addiction that could be alarmed along
those sorts of lines you know think
about you know smoking tobacco right
when you first do it you get this great
rush and feels like your lungs are you
know scrunching in on themselves and all
sorts of cool things happen your body
after a while that first cigarette in
the day may still be very pleasant taste
good but you really want it because it
you need it you needed to restore or
something that's not there coffee
caffeine addiction is like that as well
I can quite attest to that myself having
tried to wean myself off before and not
having been particularly successful so
Aristotle says that the pleasures of the
body is a little bit earlier on in the
discussion are the ones that were most
often familiar with and so he talks
about them you surfing the name of
pleasure that what he means by that is
they become for many people the paradigm
for how we understand pleasure we think
of pleasures primarily in terms of
bodily pleasures well you know what we
put in our mouths right what we do with
our mouths you know what we do with our
body or sense of touch we can think of
other pleasures as well along these
lines but bodily pleasures are the ones
Aristotle thinks that were most familiar
with so Aristotle suggests that
necessary pleasures and bodily pleasures
are examples of necessary pleasures per
tick
early baccano restorative pleasures they
are good in the sense of being knock
that right the opposite of them the pain
is actually bad maybe we want to say
well they're not great they're not
particularly good these pleasures but
insofar as they're relieving pain
they're they're good right word perhaps
they're good up to a certain point
perhaps having a glass of wine with
dinner and appreciating that glass of
wine is a good pleasure to engage it
having you know one or two drinks you
know at the party as opposed to drinking
you know 12 drinks and then you know
hectoring the bartenders until they they
cut you off difference there right you
know this is a typically Greek thing
everything in moderation Aristotle is
all about that so perhaps bodily
pleasures are in fact good for us
insofar as we enjoy them up to a certain
point now he says that's probably the
right way to look at things but we also
want to understand why people go wrong
with this why do people pursue bodily
pleasures so exclusively or so
single-mindedly to the detriment of the
other pleasures that they could be
enjoying which would in fact be better
for them they wouldn't entail pain of
some sort they having nobler they would
elevate them perhaps you know why do
people think that they should have the
lower pleasures and deprive themselves
of the higher ones so Aristotle says
here's two possible reasons for that one
is that pleasure drives out pain so
sometimes we want pleasure not for its
own sake but because pleasure will help
us do not feel a kind of pain anymore
and here he's talking about restorative
pleasures right so again think about it
when you're thirsty you really want to
drink something you probably don't even
you literally care what it is you'll
you'll drink an iced tea that you
ordinarily would never purchase because
somebody hands it to your like drink
something right and then afterwards
you're like can't believe I drink that
that garbage right so we seek bodily
pleasures as restorative I think you
could also make a case that we seek them
as what we might call compensatory so
when we're feeling pain in one respect
doesn't even necessarily have to be a
physical pain it could be psychological
pain then we often seek out bodily
pleasures he has a way to deal with that
pin called out you know self-soothing or
you know management of one's emotions
usually it's not good management right
this is part of what leads people into
over consumption or consuming things at
the wrong time or engaging in risky
behavior to try to get you know that
kick that they need it or does it not
feel bad so Aristotle is actually
talking about something like that back
in in ancient Greece he also thinks that
bodily pleasures are often favored by
those who don't know any other pleasures
here he's actually anticipating John
Stuart Mill's famous discussion in his
book utilitarianism on the difference
between qualitatively lower and
qualitatively higher pleasures or as I
sometimes put it in terms of my students
beer or books hey we need to come up
with all sorts of other things but he
says you know some people don't in fact
have a chance to enjoy better pleasures
and so bodily pleasures are the only
ones they're actually attuned to no
surprise then that they pursue those
bodily pleasures to the exclusion of
other plungers there's kind of self
reinforcing dynamic there if you are
only after bodily pleasures you're not
going to pursue the other pleasures
which sometimes take a bit of refinement
or work to get to and so then you're not
going to appreciate it you'll just keep
on going back and back to those bodily
pleasures and until you're old that's
become the habit of your life so Arizona
except bodily pleasures are and be
desirable they're not desirable you know
as much to the person who actually sees
things rightly as the higher pleasures
but for many people that's that's really
the only game in town these modeling
butters and it gives us some reasons for
understanding why it is that they have
such a hold on our desire and our
imagination